hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the Paul
Morphy saga in the first American chess
congress although this game in
particular is not a part of the matches
in the first American chess congress
although in the semifinals morphe did
the face theater or littenheim
but this is a game that was played as a
friendly game probably while they were
waiting for for the games to begin one
of the two games morphe played against
liftin hind before their actual match
now the reason I decided to show this
before the actual match is because of
the opening that was used I don't have
to tell you which opening it is now
because I'm sure you know and well it's
just a just a very exciting game and it
really shows you what a will what an
exciting opening the Evans gambit DMS
gambit is now a Theodore Lipton Hein and
he moved into the United States in 1851
and already in 1856 he became the
strongest member of the New York chess
club and now he is a 1 year after that
here in New York playing against Paul
Morphy himself so let's see how the game
went morphe opened with e4 with E 5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and the Bishop
to c4 the Italian game is on the board
Bishop to c5 now the jogo piano and of
course b4 morphe goes for the Evans
gambit as you always should when someone
plays the Joko piano so Bishop captures
on b4 best in those days and still
considered best capturing with the
knight has has the downside to put it
best if you capture with the knight and
whites let's say goes c3 you go back
then white has d4 now the main
difference here is if you capture with
the bishop and then after c3 you don't
have to go to c5 where your bishop is if
you if you capture with the night so
basically if you capture with the night
you only have one line which is not all
that great for you and if you capture
with the bishop then you have plenty of
plenty retreat there should be 5 Bishop
c5 Bishop d6 Bishop to e7 and all of
there all of them have their merits but
in this game Bishop to c5 was played so
pretty much the same as if Knight
characters was played we have castles by
morphe postponing the form for a moment
we have castles and now
Knight to f6 and here with black castles
black is out of the woods definitely but
morphe is not about to let that happen
so here b4 and this position is a
perfect example of how wrong can the
Evans gambit go for for the black pieces
now you have to make a move here for
black you have to notice that you still
haven't played d6 so that that is a bit
of a problem your Bishop is under attack
and you have to do something about it so
best here not Bishop to e7 but actually
Bishop to d6 you should keep an eye on
the e5 pawn but in the game he captures
on d4 was played and this is already
quite troublesome for black here more if
it continues with C captures on d4 d5
although it looks appealing it really
isn't because of d5 and now if you go
into trades captures captures and now
captors on g7 rook the g8 and rook e1
check black can block with Bishop to e6
and black is fine here problem is after
Bishop to g5 by white youth that you can
retreat Bishop to e7 so really it's it's
not a problem for black black is even up
in development here and you you can't
really allow a move like d3 so why it's
gonna have to waste a move and it's
gonna be perfectly fine for black so
after this he captures on d4 morphe
plate c captures on d4 and now you'll
see where the problem is Bishop to b6 is
played but you don't really have a
better Square for the bishop for example
if here just be five wins material if
Bishop to e7 it's not much better still
just be five and now if d5 like in the
line we've just shown captures here
already attacks another piece so why a
black just loses a piece so after C
character Sun be for now littenheim
played bishop back to b6 but now it's
it's it's a it's quite different because
e five is now a good move there is no
bishop to go back to east 7 after that
Bishop to g5 attack as we've shown so
here D Phi was played and yes they go
into the similar line like we've just
shown eke a present of six D captors and
c4 f captors and g7 roadblocks and now
rook to e1 with Czech and this is the
problem if you tried the same idea
Bishop to e6 now Bishop to g5 is pretty
because there is no better one c5 to
block this so you'd have to move the
Queen and now after you move the Queen
the black king is stuck in the center
you cannot castle and you can go to f8
due to the pawn so here probably Knight
c3 I just push away the Queen Queen
moves and then just d5 is crushing so
not much you can do here so after this
rook to e1 check least in Holland
doesn't go for Bishop to e6 he instead
blocks with the knight in 97 and now
Morphy air continues piling up pieces on
that night Bishop to g5 not threatening
to just capture it and win the game so
Bishop to e6 blocking the rooks attack
tonight and now Knight to c3 continuing
further development but also threatening
d5 which will again be overwhelming for
black and you could block it with c6 but
then just Bishop to f6 keeps the pawn
and and keeps the tension with the black
King stuck in the center it's not gonna
be it's not gonna be easy to get out of
this it will be impossible if Morphy of
course plays the best moves but after
Knight to c3 liftin Hein did not play c6
he instead played Bishop to a5 pinning
the night if the knight who was then the
rook is captured but to Murphy this is
child's play he just plays Knight to e4
he says ok you are welcome to capture my
rook because if you do Knight to f6 is
made since the knight now covers the d7
square but also the palm covers the f8
square the King has nowhere to go so
this would be this would be a very nice
checkmate so instead after this Knight
to e4 move Layton Hein clears the f8
square for the king so rook captures and
g7 but now it's not much better Knight
to f6 check you cannot go to these 7
King to f8 displayed and not while you
could pin the rook right away at just
attack it here first
rook the e5 first Morphy goes for a nice
roof lifts attacks the bishop here we
have c6 now the bishop is defended but
now better up to h6 and now more fees
attacking the rook here but lift and
hand finds the Knights the f5 and it's
quite the move attacks both the night
ended the bishop on h6 so here best for
more fees either Knight captures in h7
or just to gobble up this pawn but here
I imagine
there were there was some crowd around
morpheus table in a table and the more
if you wanted to impress everyone so
instead he played rook captures on e6
which is which is very creative as you
will see yeah so the knight is now
protected and well what do you do here
if you go for the bishop then rook to e8
Chuck just picks up the Queen
so of course Lee tonight captured the
rook but now Knight to g5 very
impressive stuff by Murphy
of course the rook is still pinned if
the Queen captures night the night
captures on h7 check pics of the Queen
as the rook is stopping you cannot
capture the night so here by playing
this well attractive idea he allows a
lift and hind a very creative defense he
plays King to e7 and now he's he's
threatening to run away with the King
and well now you really don't have a
better move than just to capture the
rook which is what Morphy does Bishop
captures and g7 with Knight captures and
g7 and now Queen f3 bringing the Queen
enter game and here you should really
try something like either night at 5:00
either h6
you you push away the night maybe the
tribe - up to d2 to kick away the night
this way but the move that lifts and I
listened Hein played is really a wild
one he played Queen captures on d4 and
it kind of does make sense
the rook is under attack the knight is
under attack the knight is attacked
twice now by the king and by the queen
but this move loses terribly so feel
free to pause the video and find this
move that punishes lifting time a little
Hinds idea well I have a nice sip of my
water so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on spotting the
move that Morphy played and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook to d1 this stops both threats
Queen captures anyone but also Queen
captures and f6 because if you capture
on f6 now rook d7 check wins the Queen
so King capture screen captures and have
sex it's game over and another thing
it's not that easy to move the Queen for
example if Queen c5 now it's just Rock
d7 check King to f8 and the Knight
captures on h7 with mate with the this
night covering the g8 square
so not a lot of possibilities here for
lift and Hine he played Bishop to d2 now
blocking the attack on his queen but now
morphe goes for a knight to g8 with
check giving up yet another piece so
morphe really feeling generous this game
and you have you have to capture it if
you don't capture it let's say go kingly
7 the Queen still goes goes to f7 with
chair King the 6 now Queen East 7 check
King d5 Knight f6 check you can go let's
say King II five you don't have a lot of
a lot of options here and now of course
Knight of three check justa fix up the
Queen and you are getting made it very
quickly so instead listen Hine played
rook captures here but it's not much
better
Queen to f7 chat with King to d8 and
here more if he can play a lot of moves
he could just capture the rook with
check but he plays the calm Knight to f3
and shows littenheim that he should
definitely resign here and in fact it
was in this position on move 26 that
Theodora littenheim resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the Queen is under attack once you move
the Queen rook captures here with check
is coming then probably probably a
checkmate will follow or if if black is
able to defend you can just pick up the
rock with checked and pick up the night
then Allah a lot of ideas are possible
so yeah a very impressive game by Murphy
and even though there was a lot going on
and there were some crazy variations a
lot of them the game actually lasted
only 26 moves which in those days for an
Evans gambit it is is actually quite a
lot but that's why I decided to show it
before the actual match between the two
of them in the first American chess
Congress as III thought you guys might
enjoy a nice Evans gambit game sure
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank mr. Vera
Brian burns Adam Kirk Robert Keefer and
Christian jobs for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Murphy saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
the 20/20 candidates are almost here so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day